target practice under the eyes of
President Nicolas Maduro it took place
at Fort Peres makai where in 2017 a
group of soldiers rose up against the
government this time it was about
showing loyalty are you plotting a coup
or are you constitutionalists traitors
never always loyal
Maduro seized the hand of western
governments behind opposition protests
he says they're trying to overthrow him
he knows the military is key to staying
in power opposition leader Juan Guido is
trying to convince the military to join
his side following a church service for
victims of violent street clashes he
made a direct appeal Venezuelan soldiers
I'm talking to you this is the moment to
be on the Constitution side don't be
afraid Guido's supporters are spreading
out across the country going to army
barracks to spread the word Cueto has
proposed an amnesty in a bid to convince
Venezuelan soldiers to join the
opposition none of the soldiers wants to
be seen switching sides on camera one
says that the military is still firmly
on the side of Maduro
a1 guido and his supporters hope that
this will change in the coming days okay
it's let's get more now from Jennifer
Camino Gonzalez she's a Venezuelan
journalist with DW in bomb
Jennifer how important is the military's
role in resolving this crisis well
they're critical I mean this is the
institution in Venezuela that decides
honestly because they have the weapons
who is in power and who's not at a
critical moment like this of course the
top leadership has sided with Maduro but
the thing is it is about the lower ranks
if the lower ranks break from the
military then the
weakens and then they have to sort of in
a divided situation they could mean the
difference between Maduro being strong
and Maduro being weak and so right now
as the top brass is backing him the
opposition is clearly going for those
people in the barracks of people at the
lower ranks to try to make the
difference right there now talking about
the opposition the self-declared
president guido who is medoras rival at
this point is calling for public protest
this week on Wednesday and Saturday
numerous people were killed in previous
protests what can we expect this time
well you should expect this showing
because the opposition and its
supporters are fired up right now this
this declaration this proclamation of
this interim presidency has really
breathe new life into the opposition now
of course there's a fear and many people
fear of reprisals of violence but they
know that the world is watching so I
think that we should expect people to
come out but this is also going to be
the test how many people actually come
out can the opposition bring another
showing quite like the one in the last
week on the 23rd of January it remains
to be seen but I would say that they
will come out now several European
governments including Germany have said
they will recognize wite-out as
president if Maduro doesn't call fresh
elections by Sunday
any chance of Maduro doing that it's not
likely
Maduro knows that if you were to have an
election it would also be heavily
monitored because they haven't just
asked for an election they've asked for
a credible election and this is exactly
the problem the last election that he
held he can't hold elections it's just
that the last election was was basically
deemed a sham it was it was not credible
and so he would not want to invite all
of that and all of an international
attention
not to mention that if a credible
election were to take place it is not
likely that he would win he doesn't seem
to have a hole in the population that he
used to so it would be it would be
shocking to me if he did and if he did
do that it's not likely that the
election would actually be credible now
for people who are just coming in on
this crisis Venezuela has been deal
with it for a while remind us again what
led to cuido declaring himself interim
president seguido has declared himself
interim president based on the
Constitution the Venezuelan Constitution
allows for this because if a president
is in the case of what they say which is
illegitimate or if the case ever the
president is not present then it falls
on the National Assembly President to be
the interim president until elections
can be called now what led to this
well basically 2017 is the key year that
is when Maduro decided to strip the
national assembly off of its power and
create an alternate legislature and so
because the National Assembly is
controlled by the opposition they
basically stripped the opposition from
any power so of course this this was a
move that he won but now this is the
next step Jennifer thank you so much
Jennifer Camino Gonzalez they are
talking to us from bomb
you